survivors of the Florida school shooting
are taking their demands for gun control
directly to the people in power last
night students and parents confronted
Senator Marco Rubio about why the type
of rifle used by the gunman has not been
outlawed if I believes that that law
would have prevented this from happening
I would support it but I want to explain
to you why it would not senator Rubio
was booed for his response to a father
who lost his daughter last week at
Marjory Stoneman Douglas High School
that town-hall meeting on live TV
followed a very emotional meeting at the
White House in the afternoon other
students and parents spoke directly to
President Trump
asking him to lead an effort to change
gun culture in this country the
president offered a series of possible
remedies including one controversial
idea letting teachers carry guns he'll
continue the school safety debate today
meeting with state and local officials
Margaret Brennan is at the White House
Margaret good morning good morning it
was an extraordinary gesture to bring
cameras into the room with the grieving
and it shows the president is hearing
the outcry and is willing to at least
consider taking action one by one
survivors of school shootings and their
family members shared their pain and I'm
pissed because my daughter I'm not gonna
see again I lost the best friend was
practically a brother people are dying
and we have to stop this and I'm just
begging for change we need to change
Andrew [ __ ] lost his 18 year old
daughter meadow in the Florida shooting
my daughter has no voice she was
murdered last week and she was taken
from us shot nine times on the third
floor we as a country failed our
children [ __ ] asked for more school
security but said it's not about gun
nails senior Sam Zeff whose best friend
died in the massacre wondered why it was
so easy to buy an ar-15 the assault
rifle used by the shooter I don't
understand why I could still go in a
store and buy a weapon of war as for Paz
Solutions president Trump focused on
strengthening background checks
increasing mental health services and
even arming school staff if you had a
teacher with who was adept at firearms
they could very well end the attack very
quickly this is my son Daniel mark
Barden lost his six-year-old son just
over five years ago in the Sandy Hook
elementary school massacre school
teachers have more than enough
responsibilities right now than to have
to have the awesome responsibility of
lethal force to take a life it did make
a difference they needed to hear it from
us students now we're leaving it up to
him to make the change that we need
after meeting with the president CBS
News spoke with some of the students who
said listening is not enough he heard
our cries and he talked to us and I
think he understood where we were coming
from but the NRA wasn't there I've said
arming teachers is not the answer this
is a problem because guns were brought
into our school why would we make sense
to bring more guns into school now take
a look at a picture captured by a
photographer in the room who saw the
handwritten notes that the president
carried with him to prompt empathy
questions like what can we do to make
you feel safe and simply I hear you now
that appeared to be the president's main
message that's exactly right Margaret
thank you so much